for the first time in more than 200
years Frances nortre dame cathedral will
not celebrate Christmas Mass the more
than 850 year old building is still
being restored after a devastating fire
in April
MTS tyub travelled to Paris to see how
people there will celebrate Christmas
without the annual tradition a song of
praise tinged with sadness these singers
are part of the Notre Dame choir since
the Gothic cathedral was devastated by
fire back in April they've been
rehearsing at this nearby church most
are still struggling to accept that
Christmas Mass at the iconic Cathedral
is canceled this year to think that I
was ill last Christmas and I missed
Christmas thinking that would go again
this year with no problem yeah no it's
yeah I can't believe I'm not gonna do
Christmas the cause of the blaze is
still unclear but what is is that far
more than brick-and-mortar has been
affected this film from 1948 shows the
first ever reporting of Christmas Mass
said North Sudan giving us a glimpse of
the past that reminds us why the church
remains so relevant to so many today
not even during World War one and to did
it close its doors completely despite
the extensive damage including the
collapse of its roof inspire the French
government is confident services will
resume again by 2025 in the grand scheme
of things five or six years of
renovation doesn't seem like a huge
amount of time for a Cathedral that's
855 years old but reconstruction experts
say it will likely take longer but for
Eduardo Barea that might not be such a
bad thing people are trying to
reconstruct and give everything to
rebuild it and it's maybe the
opportunity to go to other churches and
to rebuild your faith dr. Dom will
without a doubt continue to be a symbol
of faith that's already rising from the
ashes recipients this morning in Piazza
Hiab Paris I love what that woman said
about a chance maybe to rebuild your
faith find a positive and something that
obviously has meant so much to so many
people I gotta tell you I lived in Paris
for many many years and Nora Dom was
sort of the center of my world there
were mornings when I would just walk by
the sin and see the Sun rising and see
it glinting off this building it's
really sad to know that they won't be
celebrating at mass but I agree that's a
pretty cool sentiment absolutely
you